the pebble time round doesn't really
look like a SmartWatch it's not big and
bulky it doesn't scream I'm wearing a
computer on my wrist it's really small
and thin and light it comes in a bunch
of different options and colors some of
which actually look even nicer than this
one you can get it in small straps like
this one and really small straps it's
designed for people who don't want
gigantic smartwatches they don't want
the computers on their wrist there
really aren't a lot of new features or
specs here the time round has pebbles
same timeline interface which goes from
top to bottom guiding you through your
day with email notifications or calendar
events or the score from the game last
night there are some apps sure but
they're mostly really simple and really
basic you can say remind me to pick up
milk at 5:00 p.m. or you can track your
steps but those aren't really what this
is about
the time round like all pebble devices
is about just guiding you through your
day it has way more in common with a
Mickey Mouse watch than with an Apple
watch the most smart watching thing the
time round will do is send notifications
from your phone to your wrist if you're
on Android this is great you can pick
which apps can send notifications and
you can actually take action on some of
those notifications like replying to
emails or even just dismissing them
altogether if you're not I phone you
don't get any of that you get every
notification first on your iPhone and
then about a half second later on your
wrist sometimes it's useful sometimes
into chaos if you've ever been in a
group chat it feels like a full body
vibration the whole time it's crazy all
that stuff is about pebble in general
let's go back to the time round screen
it's a little dim and it's a little
bright when the lights on it definitely
calls attention to itself every time you
get a notification but the nice thing
about a screen like this is the battery
will last a long time even in this tiny
body where there's basically no room for
battery you still get about two two and
a half days of battery life before you
have to charge that thing that's much
better than having to throw it on the
charger every single night it also
charges really fast which helps to some
of the other pebbles that will last a
lot longer than this one but they don't
look nearly as good you should pick your
own trade-off but I think this one
pebble has always been really smart
about what it does it's not trying to be
everything to everyone the way the Apple
watches this is
watch only a little bit smarter and it's
dedicated towards the same thing as
every other watch getting you through
your day and telling you what you need
to know and every time you look at
pebbles problem has always been designed
and yeah the bezel on this thing is huge
and it does feel a little cheap and
tacky next to some of the other watches
even the ones that also cost two hundred
and forty nine dollars but I like the
time round it's simple and easy to
understand and it doesn't feel
overwhelming and complicated it's just a
watch a smarter watch